so this is this is this is where i'm
getting freaked out right seeing
this story out of france i saw this the
other day i i covered it a little bit
and you know uh there were some some
political leaders
in the country who said that leftist
ideology on
race and gender is destroying france and
they need to stop it
now they're to the point where their
former generals are warning macron of
civil war
and we've seen many similar articles in
the united states from prominent
publications talking about the prospect
of civil war in this country
i know a lot of people on the left like
to laugh about it but it's not a reality
but
then maybe january 6 might change their
minds
when you see what happens with chauvin
and based on the things you're telling
me where
pigs a pig's head and blood at the home
of one of the witnesses who had already
testified
a message to the jury a democrat a
federal politician
who straight up threatened more violence
she didn't say the word violence had
more confrontation
as they're already rioting and in the
context of violence
right in the context of there's only one
way to interpret of a year of riots
right and now we have we have the other
remaining
officers in the chauvin trial who are or
their trial set for august i believe
we also have kyle rittenhouse now we
have this elizabeth city case now we
have a virginia case
it not only are these instances going to
keep happening because
sometimes cops use lethal force whether
justified or not it's going to keep
happening
it will be weaponized by hard left
cultists people who believe that might
makes right and they can do whatever
they want
and then there's not going to be a
system of justice for anyone involved
cops are already resigning in mass
across the country and have been
since since last year and it's getting
worse even in the area we're in right
now a local town is facing a shortage of
police and they don't know what to do
about it
so at what point do people just say i
have no faith in this system anymore
and do we just see people
taking up arms in their own
neighborhoods rejecting
the law i mean how how does a regular
person function
in a society that has thrown out the
rule of law
well mostly you just hope it doesn't
happen to you mostly you just hope that
you don't get targeted that's the
that's the only thing you can hope for
the solution is certainly not
private justice that just makes you even
more vulnerable to successful
prosecution than if you had the
background and training and badge and
apparent authority of a police officer
you're not less vulnerable
to this kind of prosecution you're more
likely to make mistakes you're more
likely to be mischaracterized look at
the guys in the ahmad arbory case who
are making
what was almost certainly a lawful
citizen's arrest under georgia law you
may not like the georgia citizens arrest
law i get that
reasonable people can disagree but if
you read the law they almost certainly
met the conditions for making a lawful
citizen's rest of our bury
and they're not being treated like cops
they're just being treated as people who
wanted to be cops and murdered a black
man for jogging through a neighborhood
uh so i don't think private details are
relevant yeah i remember when i covered
that
and there's i believe there's
surveillance footage of him entering
this
this private property and i had these
people on the left they don't care it's
it's
they they believe there's no truth but
power and they believe might makes right
so when i come out and say like oh
there's a video the guy was trespassing
i mean
in west virginia you're allowed i'm
pretty sure i could be wrong so fact
check me on this one but i'm pretty sure
you're allowed to shoot someone to stop
them from entering your property
you don't even have to wait until they
get on your property you can prevent
them from accessing your property
well in most states if someone's
attempting to forcibly and unlawfully
enter your dwelling your place of
business your occupied vehicle
there's a legal presumption they're
doing it to cause you deadly bodily harm
which would justify your use of deadly
defensive force not new jersey
new jersey you have to run away i don't
know where you run to when you're in
your home and you have to retreat from
your own home i guess
if you're sitting in your in your in
your bed in your underwear and someone
breaks in your house
go stand in an alley somewhere in your
underwear i guess and pray for the best
but that's that's the law in some of
these places it's it's
unfortunate when that happens in the
unfortunately i certainly hope there is
not a civil war i mean when we had a
civil war last time i believe the the
death count was something like 600 000
and that's just combat deaths that's not
it doesn't even count people who starved
and suffered other catastrophes
uh a civil war in america it would
easily be 60 million
people but it wouldn't end up dying
especially in the just in time economy
in which we live and where your grocery
store in two days if it's not resupplied
is completely out of food as we learned
during the the coveted you're right
but but i'll clarify this point you know
because i
it's been a minute since we've talked
about civil war here on the show but we
we talk about it uh decently amount in
in the context of the escalation of
violence
i can't remember which guest this was
but they made a really great point
you know i often say that when people
look at civil war in the united states a
potential for it and there's there's a
princeton a professor who said
we're in a cold civil war this is not
something i just made up there
you saw this i agree we are in a cold
civil war my concern would be if it goes
hot
so here's here's the issue is that
people imagine the american civil war as
how civil wars work that's not true most
civil wars do not function this way
where you have states seceding and then
two factions fighting you know
each other that can't happen anymore not
the way we're structured
but right absolutely but even other
countries where there's been civil war
it's a bunch of different pockets rise
up and there's violence
for against local government against
different factions we had someone on the
show i can't remember who it was but
they said
what happens in america will look more
like syria yes you'll have 30 or 40
factions
you'll have different you know elements
of the government and everyone would be
fighting in in different places for
different reasons
it's not going to be structure it's just
going to be violence and chaos
and it's going to be you know different
in different areas and i think that's
that seems to be a likely scenario right
now especially based on what we're
seeing in minnesota
it may be likely i mean i certainly hope
it doesn't happen for all the reasons i
just described i think the death toll
would be unimaginable
but there's really only three options
right there's reconciliation between the
left and the right
there's civil war or there's subjugation
of the right by the left so which of
those outcomes are we going to pick i
don't see reconciliation
anywhere in our future i'd like to think
there's not going to be a civil war but
i certainly wouldn't be happy about the
third outcome
which would be effective subjugation of
49 percent of public well
subjugation is happening i mean when i
see these cops
in after everything you've just told me
about the chauvin case
uh and and the the way you presented i
mean people being brought in under armed
guard with cops
machine guns pigs blood all that stuff i
can't believe they're still police
officers who would wear that badge
because they are representing a city
that knows what they did a judicial
system that knows what they did
and they're effectively supporting it by
doing so well they're not really staying
though
so minneapolis pd has lost something
like 20 of its officers in the last year
those you you can't just apply that 20
generally because there's huge chunks of
the police force that are not
interacting with the public like street
cops they're at the academy
they're in the headquarters those people
are not leaving they're not in danger of
being derek chauvin because they're not
going hands-on with suspects
so they say 20 of the total police force
is leaving
that has to be 40 to 50 or more of the
street
cop guys are not going to get replaced
by better quality officers they're gonna
get replaced by
people like some of the cops involved in
the arrest
people it's their fourth or third call
out on the street when suddenly they
find themselves in a george floyd event
so they're more likely calls right they
make worse use of forced calls we're
going to see
more cases in which cops are using force
inappropriately and by the way i don't
want to suggest anybody that i think
cops always use force
appropriately there's many cases where
they use force inappropriately but my
observation based on my experience is
when that happens they are held
accountable
so what i object to is this notion that
cops are rampantly going around using
force inappropriately and just
society's just letting them do that
that's not true
right what's surprising to me is well
before i get to that
the rookie cops more likely to get
killed and more likely to kill right yes
absolutely bad use of forced calls less
experience poorer judgment because of
that lack of experience those are the
guys more likely to
accidentally go to the gun when they
meant to go to the taser
and you end up with more force being
used inappropriately you don't get
better outcomes by having a less
experienced police force so this is only
going to exacerbate the problem it's
going to keep happening right
then you're going to get more of these
lawyers coming out saying oh these cops
did wrong see this is proof we got to
abolish the police
this is why i'm surprised who in their
right mind would sign up to be a police
officer right now
i don't think anybody is well they have
rookies they they they have people
coming and joining the force people
people
desperate for the job who don't
understand the risks or who believe that
hey
it won't happen to me i just have to be
right because most most
officers are not involved in a george
floyd type of case
but of course it's not up to the cop i
mean one thing most people i don't think
they realize
it's not really the cop who decides how
much force
to use in an encounter with a violently
non-compliant suspect
it's the suspect who determines how much
force is going to be used
so it's not really within the cops
control unless the cop decides
i'm not going to engage i'm not going to
go hands-on i'm just going to let this
person go
and whose interests is that in i mean
it's cities where the police have long
adopted that kind of approach
that have become the high crime
hellholes and not for people who live in
rich suburbs but for the people who live
are caught captured trapped in those
urban
centers and violence who by the way when
they're asked they want more police they
don't want the police defunded
however we've seen from gallup that many
people in these places
do say they want more cops but i don't
see them coming out to support the
police i don't see them going to
fundraisers i don't see them marching in
the streets so the way
the way i see it is you can tell me you
want something but if you've got people
setting fires to buildings destroying
them completely beating people in the
streets smashing windows
that's the voice being heard in the
press and you won't even stand up
outside with a sign
you've abstained from the vote right you
have to put your your vote where your
mouth is and if you don't do that
nothing changes but in fact nothing
changes i mean just look at the school
systems in these same places
those school boards are elected by the
residents in those communities
and they continue to elect people who
don't educate their children so
indoctrinate their children what are we
supposed to make of that again they
don't put their votes where they
say their mouth is so we've seen a
massive escalation in violent crime
across the country we've seen shootings
skyrocketing i think new york it's like
what 250 percent or something ridiculous
275 some ridiculously large number
cops are at a point now where i'm we've
already seen many resign i think in
albuquerque recently
20 officers resigned from their
emergency response team so no more riot
right control
they're going to bring in rookies cadets
to be trained though that'll go well
so we're going to get more of these
instances but we're also going to hear
more of cops saying i'm not going to
either i'm going to quit the job and go
somewhere else
i've gotten those emails or we're going
to see cops who just say i won't respond
to that call
gun violence and crime will continue to
skyrocket in places like new york
chicago and i believe l.a of obviously
the big cities
and then what happens when someone
finally says i'm going to fight back or
i'm going to form my own neighborhood
watch group and we're going to take up
arms
now you see the emergence of urban
factions
opposing uncontrollable violence yeah
that's that's that's the seed for some
serious urban conflict i
understand the the drivers that would
lead people to want to protect their own
communities their homes by forming these
private little cooperative groups
uh the legal jeopardy they're creating
for themselves is unbelievable because
if something goes bad if they are then
involved in some kind of george
floyd-like event
the prosecutors will characterize it as
a conspiracy among the group
each and every one of them will be
equally responsible for the worst
conduct of any of their members
so if it turns out there's some lunatic
in your group that you didn't realize
was a lunatic until he got a chance to
point a gun at somebody and he murdered
someone straight out murder someone
if you're deemed a co-conspirator you
committed that murder my friend
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time